-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good to hear.
In that case,
let's get to the news.
House Republican leader
Kevin McCarthy failed to secure
enough votes to ascend
to the Speakership today
after a fifth ballot.
Incidentally, a fifth is also
what he drank during the vote.
[ Laughter ]
"Son of a gun."
20 House Republicans voted
against GOP leader
Kevin McCarthy
during today's fifth
Speaker ballot.
God, you guys can't even have
a red wave amongst yourselves.
[ Laughter ]
The White House said yesterday
that President Biden has
no plans to intervene
in the House Speaker election
after Republican Kevin McCarthy
failed to secure enough votes
during the second ballot
to ascend to the Speakership,
at least not until it stops
being hilarious.
[ Laughter ]
During his inaugural address
yesterday,
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
criticized Democrats' agenda
and said, quote, "Florida
is where woke goes to die."
In fact,
it's where
everything goes to die.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So, to be fair.
According to newly released
Congressional testimony,
ex-White House adviser
Kellyanne Conway said
that former President Trump
is afraid
of former First Lady
Melania Trump.
Well, she IS an immigrant.
[ Laughter ]
Disgraced...
Disgraced cryptocurrency
exchange founder
Sam Bankman-Fried pleaded
not guilty yesterday
in federal court
on a series of charges
including money laundering,
which from the looks of him
may be the only thing
he's ever laundered.
[ Laughter ]
The Southwest Airlines
pilot union
published a letter yesterday
denouncing the carrier's
leadership and said
the company was turning
into a cult.
Even worse, they only give you
half a Kool-Aid.
[ Laughter ]
Anytime you can make a joke
both about how small
the beverage servings are
on airlines
and Jonestown...
[ Laughter ]
...comedy gold.
A woman in West Virginia
recently had her wallet
returned to her
nearly 55 years after she
lost it at a high school dance.
"That's not all she lost,"
said her 54-year-old daughter.
[ Laughter ]
You guys did the math
very quickly.
[ Laughter ]
The makers of International
Delight coffee creamer
have announced they will release
a new flavor
inspired by the Central Perk
coffee shop on "Friends."
Although, I don't know
if you can call vanilla "new."
[ Laughter ]
Two people in Florida
were arrested recently
after one of them allegedly
called 911
to get help moving items
from a home
they were burglarizing.
But to be fair,
the police did help.
[ Laughter ]
It's a jail cell.
When you put too much
nice furniture in a jail cell,
it just looks like a studio
apartment in New York City.
[ Laughter ]
Like, everybody saw that,
they were like, "Well, ehhh..."
[ Laughter ]
"You say I get
three meals a day?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a man in Idaho
recently set
a Guinness World Record
after stomping 100 balloons
in 22.38 seconds.
It was for Most Ruined
Birthday Party.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!